make of these figures uh some suggesting
pretty much broadly in line with with
expectation
well they're actually uh slightly worse
than expectations to be honest neil the
market was looking for around
15.8 percent growth during the quarter
it got 15.5
so that was uh slightly uh less than uh
expected
and for the month of september that was
well shy of expectations month on month
the market was looking
for growth of one and a half percent it
got 1.1
and that really clearly does show that
the momentum that was gone
during the uh summer really did start to
eberway during september
obviously we had the eat out to help out
scheme during august there's no doubt
that that was a major phillip
to economic activity likewise the uh
stamp duty holiday that has contributed
to an to
an uptick in economic activity but on
the whole the numbers are not
pretty good to be honest if you look at
what annalise dodd said she actually
understated the
extent to which the economy has
contracted we're uh we're actually now
9.7 percent lower the size of the uk
economy
than we were at the end of last year
some 8.2 percent
lower than we were going into the crisis
at the end of february that is a
contraction that is far more
uh marks than in any of the uk's major
industrial competitors the likes of
france germany even italy haven't con
contracted to that extent
now that is not necessarily all the
government's fault it partly reflects
the structure of the uk economy the fact
that uh the uk is far more of a
services-based economy
than a lot of those uh other peers that
i've just mentioned and if obviously if
you look at manufacturing it's been far
easier to uh
continue in uh productive activity uh
while maintaining uh social distancing
protocols that's not necessarily been
possible
in large swathes of the services sector
and that partly goes to explain
why the uk's contraction has been so
much worse than a lot of its
international
competitors